I turned to my right right now and the
host of Showtime sports new digital
talk-show below the belt and a man who's
not only working for Showtime but
working for E and is his set at The
Comedy Store in La Jolla California
tonight is sold out
he is Brendan Schaub back here on the
Rich Eisen show you look you were you
were just the near the all-around
Renaissance man here I'm just trying to
get paid like these college kids rich
things are good things are good man
appreciate you this one my favorite
shows thank you one of my favorite shows
are doing yeah I appreciate that I
appreciate you saying that so what is
below the belt
that's debuting next Wednesday what is
below the belt you know it started with
the idea cuz I worked the Conor McGregor
Floyd Mayweather fight for Showtime
and I'm a huge boxing fan I started in
boxing that's my background I was a
Golden Gloves champ
and then I made my way over to the UFC
and there seems to be especially when I
do all the the PR for that big boxing
match with McGregor and Floyd with
there's the boxing fans and MMA fans and
they hate each other there's no middle
man there's no middle ground okay and so
we get done with that huge event when
the biggest boxing events of all time
and we're sitting at the table and
Showtime goes what now what now and I
want you guys have this MMA audience in
there they're finally engaged in boxing
you need to piece it together okay and
they said that's why you're here and
said what you got anything any ideas and
here's below the belt so I'm a boxing
fan I'm a mixed martial arts fan
entertainment fan pop culture fashion so
it's kind of this comedy variety sports
show all mixed into one and it's on
YouTube and Facebook starting next
Wednesday of February 28th and but below
the belt podcast premieres March 6 so
you just got it all working right now I
got it work in the below-the-belt
podcast and my fans if there's some out
there there are I have the big round
break down
nothing changes I'm just changing the
name the big brown breakdown which is
tongue twister yes it's below the belt
so it's all the same Brandon's make
success right yeah it was confuse me but
you're naming your podcast in your show
after an illegal maneuver it is illegal
you understand well you know why because
I watch the the you know not anything
against other sports shows there
especially fight shows I've seen it all
before you know so this is just a little
mix-up how about
your face you know in your grill in your
grill people nuts well I mean that's
that's just too much well I a QC but
below the belt is a more classy way of
saying what you just said I know you
know what I mean I know it's kind of
like we're talking about stuff that look
you're you are certainly if you're gonna
be red carpeting and you're gonna be
doing that sort of stuff in your career
don't watch your P's yes sir well no I
think you need to be more in the
numerator than the denominator I know I
know you don't mind me simply use this
advice before we name the show it's
don't worry off and running it still
worked a lot of bad foot who's gonna be
your first guest man we had some good
ones we got Deontay Wilder who's the
heavyweight champ who actually fights
next weekend and so our show airs before
that and then we have Frankie Edgar who
also fights next weekend in the UFC
he's fighting Brian Ortega the the UFC
legend and if Paulie Malignaggi who I'd
do a game with a bit I call shot for
shot where he's five tequila shots yeah
and if Paulie agrees with me as take a
shot if he doesn't have to cut some fun
times so when he gets all hammered can
we find out what was his role actually
in the McGregor entire week I tried you
see so was he was he mul was he not a
mole for regret for for Mayweather what
what was Malignaggi G's rolling yeah he
wasn't a mole he wasn't a mole he you
know what happened was he went in there
and he had assumptions that they were
just gonna use him kind of pick his
brain on stuff and they were kind of
used them just to prove a point you know
and he wasn't in shape he got off the
plane went 12 rounds and you get beat up
when that happens man I do believe he
got dropped but all the odds were
against him there's a bad idea okay so
now what is the scoop with McGregor and
UFC right now because Dana White
basically said they're gonna he's gonna
lose his title because he's not fighting
what's that mean these days titles it's
right now we're in an entertainment era
so everyone wants a super fight so
titles don't mean much so what we want
to see is McGregor fighting that's what
harassing whether it's for a Tyler or
not well one one one when are we gonna
see that best you can tell fairly soon I
think you'll see him in 2018 you know
they did just announce they
they're having a show in Dublin which I
think would be his best bet you know and
he did on social media say that he was
gonna take the short on the fight on
short notice against Frank Jaeger cuz
his opponent max Holloway got hurt he's
gonna take the fight on short notice in
two weeks but Dana from Connors
perspective said no we don't have enough
time to market we can't pay you that
much right now so let's hold off now
Frankie Edgar's manager came out went
wow that never happened I tend to side
with Connor on this knowing Conor and I
think he hit up Dana and he actually did
want to take the fight but so sometimes
doesn't get to the managers so I'll side
with Connor honest okay so scon err when
you say for those who might not be
familiar when you say you side with
Connor on this what do you mean by that
friend meaning I do think you you would
be open to taking the fight on short
notice I do think he's in fighting the
UFC i I think he's waiting to see what
happens with that interim title if it is
an interim title getting titles make no
sense but with khabib Naga Murdoch and
Tony Ferguson are fighting for the
155-pound title right depend on the
winner that'd be Connors next decision
it could if kabhi wins I don't think he
wants to fight him if Tony wins he well
fight him Tony Ferguson or he can just
chill out with his hundred million
dollars yeah be on yachts do his gucci
thing and then maybe fighting Nate Diaz
that fights never go in anyway how the
hell was he not in a Guy Ritchie movie
already I mean he's like he's perfect
for something like that you know he
turned down a role in Game of Thrones
cuz he was focused on training come on
I know I got game of throne boots what
do you would he would he put a little
bit more meat on those bones what do you
mean he turned down a role he had a lot
of yeah a lot of offers to do to do what
the predator remake they're doing a game
of Thrones the Hollywood's calling his
name but he's focused on fighting he
also has a hundred million dollars it's
tough to you've been on SATs it's tough
to kind of hurry up and wait play
make-believe Brendan Schaub here on the
Richardson show does UFC have a star
problem because we're sports in general
of a prom you know boxing is supposed to
been dead forever you know it's on its
last leg it's on its last leg and box is
never been better so many damn stars
they don't know what to do with it
there's great stars in box right now NBA
goes same thing in a fail they just have
this surplus of athletes and I mean
stars look we know look I mean the
combine that's coming up next week we've
got like 6 7 8 9
quarterback's I'm coming into the NFL
say Quan Barkley by this point next week
will have run his 40-yard dash and
everyone has to be talking about him etc
but seriously I mean in the UFC
we're wondering where is Conor McGregor
Ronda Rousey joining wrestling is a
conversation more than most from that
world right so that's what I'm saying is
does you at does the UFC have a next set
of people that can break through and
capture the imagination of a casual
sports fan to tune in and more
importantly for them put on hard-earned
American dollars to watch this fight
yeah that's a great point you know III
think that's always the question and I
think you know when Chuck Liddell
retired when Tito Ortiz retired Connor
being out John Jones being out you know
and you have the heavyweight champ who's
been out so whenever these guys go out
people know they're done they're done so
someday always find someone you know but
listen they have a business model
problem you know their business model
that rides and dies on superstars and
people paying basically $70 for HD
pay-per-views that's their problem
I think you know the pay-per-view model
is the issue it's it's tough these days
it's tough there's too much to compete
with well but that's that said you know
of the many and in all honesty and I'll
say this because I enjoy you coming on
here and so many folks from your world
of octagon and square ring fighting you
there's it just seems that you all want
to do something else too because you
don't want to get your brains for so
long it depends who you talk to you
ignorant is bliss so for me I was
terrified to fight and you know and my
dream was to be a comedian my hair's
where Jim Carrey and Adam Sandler grown
up so I just was blessed with you know I
was fast and bigger than everyone so my
dad was like for sure pick up a football
quit acting like an idiot so I was
fortunate that aspect kind of but a lot
of these guys they love fighting that's
all they know the ones you have on here
are here for a reason because they're
one of the few that can speak and
articulate things very well but in
general you know those world champions
like st pay me o j-- it's Tony Ferguson
khabib these guys they that's all they
care about is fighting right well only
you're the only one I know that turned
golden gloves into golden globes I know
see where I just went on
I'm a little too into fashion where you
say you did the channel Post Golden
Globes you did all that slogan globes my
first run with them and I did the
Grammys in New York and I'm doing the
Oscars next weekend you doing the Oscars
soon Aussies man see now he's doing the
Oscars I'm doing the combine that day
something wrong with this picture I
don't know man you gotta watch bunch of
dudes run 40-yard dashes and tights
depends what you're into fashion I mean
it seems pretty simple don't you feel
like we'd be the same thing if you just
hear that I don't know all right let's
take a break we'll come as they will
we'll get deeper into this Brendan
Schaub is here on the Rich Eisen show
Gabe Feldman of the Tulane sports law
programs joining us in the middle of
this hour part of your newscast what
else you have on your news all teed up
Brock big NFL trade that just went down
rich what what began a felt raid that
just went down that just went down well
I'll tell you what that's not we're not
waiting for your news update in the
middle they out we're gonna get to that
next yeah we'll get to that I have to
know yeah so you know NFL news that I
don't write I do he's going to the
Oscars I'm going to the compound yeah
out of you're losing our cats and dogs
playing together behind me in the 18th
and thoroughfare know is happening and I
have a remix what do you mean Oh from
laboratory show yeah got it Barry
Melrose in our number three and buckets
Blake's we've got some Harlem
Globetrotters making their way to the
studio that's how we are rolling here on
this Friday show
hi Brendan Schaub still with us here
Showtime sports below the belt
it will debut next Wednesday February
28th on YouTube and Facebook and then
you're a correspondent on after-party
for the e Network you did that post
Golden Globes you did that post Grammy
Awards hmm excuse me for missing that
all right and I but I'm into this sort
of stuff are you so what is it you and a
co-host what are you it's a panel it's a
panel I'd appreciate can be me and one
other person with the post show the
after-party it's me it's a panel okay we
have people who else like Morgan Stewart
okay um there's a slippery stylist
there's there's a bunch of us so you
know you're on the Oscar afterparty
come on Oscar after I'm coming with some
hotness no bards fashion okay what do
you have I have a wall break news here I
do like you rich all breaking news here
it is a crushed velvet burnt gold jacket
with black lapels and some black tuxedo
pants damn shoe so basically you're
gonna look like an Oscars what you're
saying kind of out there I caught
peacocking you know yes I support the
cause the me to movement when I did the
Golden Globes and beer with me I did
going Globes yes I was super excited cuz
I'm really into fashion I'm working for
E they gave me a celebrity stylist as ID
to wear all black we all look like we're
in a funeral all good for is not fun but
at least you did it yeah well yeah I
support the cause but just it's your
first one and if we're all black so when
how many of the oscar-nominated films
have you seen I'd say at least half at
least half that's part of the gig man I
gotta watch that stuff yeah yeah dude
you need to make up some time what have
you what some of the born once I don't
cuz I only talk about what I like really
so but you have to know see I Tanya I
have not seen height on you yet you saw
doing red I saw it you saw I saw Britain
okay and you yet what did you think you
thought it was it way too sympathetic it
was good but I'm not into the narrative
of Tonya Harding as a sympathetic figure
and also Margot Robbie way too
attractive to play Tonya Harding with
all due respect we would you have player
I would have done the movie some weight
like the movie monster have you seen in
the shape of water I have seen shape of
water that's a good movie good love
story we like a Beauty and the Beast
under one
well yeah an alien yeah correct it it's
a little too out there for me this is my
thing on that one was one you know one
of those it's art movies I like art sees
anybody else I mean it was one of those
you know lights come up suit wife and I
look at each other like what what the
hell was that we had Richard Jenkins
who's who's nominated he was here and I
asked him I'm like whoa what was that
about
you know did he have a good answer to
have a good answer it doesn't it doesn't
ring a bell right now is it an hour-long
answer it was a very uh you know
Guillermo del Toro has you know without
on you know think if you're a Nancy
Kerrigan like she's the star she it's a
freaking Oscar now how's this work well
I mean she also she also let's not
forget she took it to the knee she
actually did she got assaulted it also
makes you realize that these were for
the dumbest people on earth who thought
they were going to get away with right
that's why it's so good it's so good
I'll never forget Charley Steiner did
the Brendon shop here in the Richard
Rowe Charley Steiner did the reader on
SportsCenter when when Tonya Harding and
Jeff Gillooly her husband broke up and
he read the details of the break-up and
one of them got the tool shed in the
break-up
and he could not get through it oh you
must all you must he Charlie could not
get through it please rating all that up
did you see get out yes that is great
movie uh to me that was one of the I
understand it's you know pop culture its
horror but in terms of movies that I've
seen this year how original is it it's
one of the best movies I've seen all
year amazing did you see three
billboards did you see that yes I enjoy
well I mean you can't say I enjoyed that
it gets pretty damn tough but it's well
done if you can say that yes you could
well duh
now you're the Oscar get the gig well
done
okay so what would you give the best
picture to what's your best picture that
you've seen this year I'd give it to get
out as far as originality there just the
overall product I'll give it to get out
did you ever see Rosemary's Baby from
back in the day I did not you don't see
that you need to see that it's very very
similar to rose when did that come out
oh gosh late 60s I believe yeah no
latency for sure mr. Shawn dude don't be
one of those guys I got a young man and
I don't watch the oldest movie you've
ever seen
do not commando you say something from
the 92 man though you cannot allow to
save something funny jean-claude Van
Damme cyborg okay Tanja gets to keep the
pickup truck Michael keeps the tool
chest you have just seen the star
witness Charlie so I guess it wasn't
Gillooly it was her and another all
right I have not seen I Tanya yeah it's
a darker money to see darkest hour and I
need to see phantom thread right it was
that with the guy who says he retired
but then didn't retire and I'm on so
he's the Daniel D are you saying Daniel
day-lewis is the Brett Favre of acting
so it's Hank no I'm saying he's to Ben
Roethlisberger of he really wants you to
know how much he's an actor Daniel
day-lewis he's retiring so others can
win Oscars correct he might be the
greatest really wants you to know how
much he loves being an actor and getting
into each role he's like the Ben
huntzberger of that he's not Ben
Roethlisberger you'd be like if Tom
Brady retired okay that's how good of an
actress he's the best burger always
wants you to know how injured he is and
how much he's battling through me
cutting it out by the way Brendan
this is a guy who judges so many books
by the cover that he thinks he sees all
the time now you as a former athlete you
must deal with that right I'm just a
meathead do this you meathead I'm just
too big meat cut you with your
cauliflower your cauliflower ears leave
me oh my bounce or two is that what
you'd like have you gone sir sure have
no idea what Daniel day-lewis goes into
to prepare for a role he tells us he was
a shoe cobbler for five years in London
get ready for a role that's Riddle when
you cobble shoes in London for half a
decade Brockman then come back and back
the time it look tended to be Abraham
Lincoln just for that I mean he will
drink your milkshake and drink it up man
he will shut the show down there will be
blood was he was incredible in that
movie that was a great movie I am
yeah what about gangs in New York thanks
to the butcher oh my gosh what are we
doing over the only watches Jeremy Irons
movies when they're in the dot when he's
in die hard like expendable 17 type of
guy fast and furious in the in gangs in
New York he put a glass contact lens and
he was literally tapping his own eye
with a knife we call that going all-in
actions of a crazy person or profess
actor of all time maybe I mean
professional he is leaving the business
to another reason again you know as I'm
watching the NBC coverage and cost this
is not there you're telling me I got a
chance this year this is you know all of
us in the business you know or put her
tapes in for best studio host Costas is
he's like Daniel day-lewis he's tapping
out he's out of here man return out at
Brendan Schaub on Twitter the fighter
and the kid upcoming tour dates sold out
tonight you doing a gig tonight
this is just Brendan Schaub yeah no more
final sprint shop stand-up yeah tonight
all four shows sold out in the hole
tonight tomorrow and then I'm on in
March you're in Oxnard home of the
Cowboys or used to be for training camp
Tampa Florida West Palm Beach Orlando
San Jose I'm all over for you dude that
is not easy you're just you're you're
doing tour dates you're doing stand-up
and then you're gonna show up post
Oscars and totally fake it because you
haven't seen Lady Bird was sublime no I
have seen Lady Bird okay they sent me
the movies man all you get screeners yes
come on you humble bro come on bro all
right we'll take a break we'll come back
in 60 seconds Chris Brockman with a news
update we didn't even get to that NFL
trade there has been a trade in the
National Football League player who's
been rumored to be on the move is in
fact going to be on the move and then
what will happen to all these players
and programs that are named in the Yahoo
Sports piece is it possible that
sanctions can happen right now before
the NCAA tournament gabe Feldman of the
Tulane law sports programs gonna join us
and then your phone calls if you're on
hold we'll still take them as Brendan
Schaub thank you for coming here Thank
You Man
back in 70 seconds with Chris Brockman's
up the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience